ghostwire tokyo is almost upon us and i
know that i've loved the trailers but
i'm not i'm still not quite sure what
kind of a game this is uh so i am joined
by john luksaipi who has been playing
ghostbuyer tokyo and he's gonna tell me
all about it john luke thank you for
joining me thank you for having me yeah
i've i've been i got to check out the
first two chapters of a preview build of
the game uh we're able to kind of show
and talk about the second chapter uh
which is
huge i actually haven't even finished
the second chapter um after a good like
five six hours and um it is it is
massive i will say that i also was just
not really sure what this game was i
knew i loved its vibes but i i wasn't
sure what you were gonna do with it and
now that i have played it i can say that
what i have played i absolutely love and
if they can keep up the momentum uh this
might end up being one of my favorite
games this year wow okay so big big
praise um and yeah so ghostway tokyo i
guess the elevator pitch is it's a new
one from horror master shinji makami
um very kind of like a stylized tokyo
uh people have gone missing
and you have these kind of awesome
powers it's in first person these
awesome powers that you can use
but like i've i've watched the trailers
and i still don't really get a
grasp of what you actually do in this
game beyond using these kind of
elemental powers so
let's dive into it like what what is the
setup what kind what what do you do in
it okay so it's basically an open world
game if you're familiar with evil within
two and the way that game kind of handle
open world where it was
the small kind of like pockets of like
open world where it's like okay i get to
kind of explore for a bit and then it
would maybe kind of go back into
something more linear and then it would
kind of open back up again this feels
more like an evolution of that where um
it is kind of these like pockets of open
worlds you get at a time but this time
it's all one massive map that is kind of
connected where evil within two it was
like a couple different maps so at the
beginning of the game you are confined
to this very small section of shibuya
which is where the game takes place the
rest of the map is covered in this
deadly fog that will kill you if you try
and go anywhere
so it it it isn't like you just have
this unlimited freedom to go anywhere
you want but as you progress through the
main story you will find these tory
gates that when you cleanse will
like expel the fog and reveal more of
the map so you're basically slowly going
through the map
cleansing these areas and like revealing
more parts of it each time you do that
you'll open up like ah like now there's
some side quests over here and now
there's like some shops and stuff like
that so
it is open world but it is designed in a
way where you kind of take it in like
small chunks and because of that it
never feels
massive in an overwhelming way uh it
feels very dense where it's like i got
this small little district but there's a
lot to do in this district and you kind
of like pick it clean and then you just
said okay i'm ready to move on and then
you go to the next district and you kind
of keep doing that okay so i i yeah are
those tour gates like is there any kind
of leveling system like could i just not
go around and just cleanse every single
one so there's like some torii gates
that you can go cleanse that kind of
seem to be more related to like this is
probably like a got more optional side
stuff
a lot of like the major sections are
tied to the story so it is more like i'm
ready to progress the story i'm gonna go
kind of like cleanse the next area and
then you unlock sort of like the next
part of the map but uh it there are
points where it kind of opens up and
says like hey if you want you can go
over here and you can cleanse this area
and it'll probably unlock a side quest
um like collectibles you can find and
stuff like that awesome so like these
side quests are they kind of are they
meaty is it or is it just like hey go
here go like this the side quests are
great again if you familiar with evil
within two how that game worked with
side quests where they were essentially
these like really cool little vignettes
where you would just um you would find
like a house and you'd be like i'm gonna
go in this house and you would kind of
get this really cool little
moment uh revolving around like a
certain enemy type or a certain little
story
and they all felt very unique
and that is exactly how it works in this
game is you'll be like i need to go
cleanse this bath house that is flooding
and it's been corrupted by evil spirits
or there's this uh cursed doll that
killed this spirit and he wants me to go
find the doll and burn it and you have
to go hunt the doll down there's never
been any repeating content for me it's
every quest has been its own unique
little thing with its own unique little
story
uh and taking place in its own unique
environment and that's been like the
coolest part about it because it feels
really you want to go do all that stuff
because you know that everything you do
is gonna be like its own unique little
moment so you mentioned the evil within
two a couple times um and you know kind
of influences uh from that game
shinji mikami is probably best known for
resident evil 4 is there any influence
from that game or any of his others so
as far as what type of game this is i
wouldn't call it a straight up survival
horror in the way like an evil within or
resident evil is um it's not trying to
scare you it is trying to creep you out
though like it is a very creepy game
uh
i mean the atmosphere of the city is
just
gorgeously haunting like the the whole
you know setup is everyone kind of
disappeared so it's just like imagine
the city of shibuya but like there's
just piles of clothes everywhere where
people were but everything is still
running so you still have you know like
music playing in the shops and all the
street signs are up but just like
nobody's there and it's it's
really well realized as someone who's
been to shibuya i mean we both went on a
trip once it is amazing how well
realized it is it looks exactly like
shibuya and just walking around where it
feels like it's influenced by
mikami's style is in the combat the
combat if you've seen it you're using
these weird like hand jutsu's to fight
these spirits essentially your hands are
different like spirit guns you have oh
hell yeah oh wait so so i'm not gonna
get told off and doing like finger guns
no you were essentially like finger gun
shooting these spirits and so you you'll
start with like this basic one that's
like oh it does this basic kind of like
blast and then you get one that does
this more powerful fire shotgun blast it
feels very resin evilly is that you have
this balance of okay i have these
different powers with these different
ammo types that do kind of that can kind
of work against different enemies and
there are a absolute ton of enemy
variety that they're slowly introducing
and the balance becomes okay that enemy
is going to be like shooting projectiles
i should probably take them out right
away but i have this enemy who's like a
rush type that stuff all feels very
makami when you're playing it i will say
the combat does feel very simple
especially in the beginning
you know when you just have the one
power it's like yep i just shoot the guy
and and they die as you get more powers
and as you get more enemies you can like
feel the complexity like coming in and
and that's where i'm very excited to see
where it goes it's like as it progresses
and and hopefully i think it can keep
that momentum up but even when it's
simple it feels really satisfying just
the and the hand animations are so well
done every time you um you can knock an
enemy into a state where then you use
your your like ethereal weaving to like
pull their core out and you'll do this
move where you use these like wires to
just like
snap them
it's the most satisfying animation every
time you do it it feels so good
[Applause]
even though the combat is simple i think
just the they've nailed the presentation
of it so much that you you just like you
feel so good uh every time you you do it
awesome uh so you've been playing for a
good few hours now what are sort of the
small and we talked about the big things
i suppose but what are the what are the
small things that have been sticking out
to you uh i this game feels like it has
a lot of like really cool like attention
to detail moment so i mentioned shops a
lot uh all of the shops have been taken
over by these cat yokai that have come
into the city the game has a database
that will actually like break down all
the different like spirits and stuff and
can actually give you like a history
lesson on like the real world sort of
like inspiration for them which is great
but for the cat yokai they were like no
one knows why they came to shibuya but
we think they're trying to get some uh
ethereal catnip and they're trying to
raise money for it which is why they've
taken over all the shops which i love i
think that's so cute uh there's a little
shopkeeper jingle um at like the family
mart style shops which is
lovely
[Music]
one of the cats made a resident evil 4
reference which uh fantastic wait there
are dogs you can find that you can not
only pet but if you have dog food you
can give them dog food and then they'll
they'll go find like money for you
uh there's like little tanooki that you
have to go find that like disguise
themselves and you'll so you'll find
like a trash can with like a tail and
you're like ah it's a tanooki hidden
there
it's both creepy but it's like they're
having a lot of fun with with the yo-kai
spirit aspects of it also we haven't
really talked much about the story
mostly because i kind of want to keep it
vague but the basic premise is that you
play as a young boy named um akito who
is uh been saved by a spirit named kk
that has possessed his body that allows
him to use his powers so they kind of
have this jujutsu kaizen almost
antagonistic relationship at first and
as you play through the game like they
kind of get to know each other they have
a lot of dialogue between them even
incidental stuff like for example i just
randomly uh hopped on top of a car and
then they started talking about like oh
how weird it is that like i can just
like jump on a car now because no one's
around
they clearly put a lot of effort into
just like adding this little dialogue
that kind of builds their
characterization
and there's a lot of other like little
tiny touches you can buy clothing and
change your outfit if you want you have
a music player that you can just like
collect different like j-pop and stuff
and then you can just listen to it if
you're like this game's too creepy for
me i want to put some j pop on
what is impressing me and making me just
like really having a fun time with it is
that you can tell there's so much love
put into the game and that they put in
this side quest or they put in this like
cat shopkeeper because they just thought
it was cool and they think it would be
fun to have it in the game
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm really enjoying my time with it but
uh for me i think the big question is
going to be whether it can like maintain
that momentum
for its entire length i'll be very
curious of that but if it can keep that
up
i think this game will be really cool
well i'm very excited to play it won't
have long to wait we're gonna have a
bunch more on ghost y tokyo so make sure
you keep your eyes peeled to gamespot
sub uh and like the video if you are so
inclined we'll catch you next time
[Music]
you